he never said to me I've got a problem  with what you are doing in Ukraine never  once never winked never sent me a little  note he is a personal friend I thought  so here's the only conclusion I can come  to and it's a harsh one and I feel very  bad about it he's a backstabber that's a  serious thing it's not serious it's true  if your friend was complaining about you  behind your back  and didn't have the guts to come up to  your face and tell you I think you're  screwing up Catherine that'd be a  backstabber  that's classic backstabber so I feel I  got a swamp character here I find his  testimony about the president pretty  close to incredible I can't imagine that  the president eights said that to him  you